welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down the end of Loki season
2 throughout this video we're going to
be going through what happens in it and
also big theories for where things are
going to go going to assume if you've
clicked on an ending explain video that
you've seen the last episode so there's
there's no need for a spoiler alert is
there mate what I'm going to do though
is beg for a thumbs up so if that snoy
little comment there didn't put you then
please hit it like it's your sexy
variant technically it's selflove and
with that out the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into Loki
season
2 okay so the entry ends with Loki sat
on the throne at the End of Time
controlling all the branches that he's
able to hold in place finally he's
realized the purpose of ruling and that
it requires sacrifice and giving things
up this is something that he struggled
with early on and the mcu's actually
shown he didn't understand it all the
way back in the first Avengers he came
down to earth and had the people bowing
down before him however as Thor said I
don't think yourself above
them oh yes then you miss the truth of
ruling brother and in the end he didn't
fully get it now it's important to bear
in mind that the ly we follow in the
show breaks out from this though the one
in the main timeline still shares the
same beliefs even in thought dark will
they said all this because Loki desires
a throne it is my Birthright which shows
that he thought leadership could be
given instead of being earned in time
theater 25 he also told Mobius that he
wanted to be someone who was seen as a
king however the finale was very much
him going through the right path and
discovering for himself that he has to
give up that idea he spend Century
Learning Obi and Victor's knowledge and
also puts himself out on the bridge
instead of forcing the ladder huge shout
outs to cat Lego M who on our last video
pointed out there's a lot of symbolism
here the ly walks out we see his robes
and Crown being formed but there's
something different about them this time
around whereas in the past he's had
nothing but golden finery here he's got
a busted up crown and very shabby
clothes this shows how his mentality's
changed and that he no longer viewed
leadership as being full of Splendor
another thing cat Lego pointed out was
what he didn't though Ragnarok when we
caught him pretending that he was Odin
man was just lying around being fed
grapes you know not hitting the thumbs
up and it showed that he thought
leadership was about self-satisfaction
when you think about it the only reason
that he even teamed up with Thanos was
so that it could be given the planet to
rule over this is even shown to US
during a what if episode in which we see
the aftermath of his Rule and how it
leads to our downfall now though he's
given up at all and this is so the TVA
can build something better whilst he
holds on to the threats this doesn't
fully mean that the war is averted but
in the end he's going to try and retain
as many threats as he can hold a ly
taking over something that's been
foreshadowed quite a lot and even in the
opening shut of the Season we got a clue
towards this this had kangs faces a big
statue which Loki then ran in front of
covering it up shortly after he then
cracked his face highlighting that the
empire was crumbling we also then had
the TVA symbol getting cracked on the
floor before we finish with him
destroying the timekeeper mural the
mural itself had a tree in the middle
highlighting the tree that he'd create
with the timelines the timelines being
represented as a tree is something that
we've seen before and this also showed
up during across the spiderverse now on
top of this I went back and started
rewatching the series with my wife and
we got up to episode 3 before I hit this
at Victor timely show you can also catch
some trees in the painting behind him
this foreshadowing the series is so so
good and I also Totally Miss this line
as well because all science is fiction
until it's F episode five was called
science fiction and that entire entry
wrestled with the who he who remains was
thought to be the best but in the end it
was Loki that took over it all roner
also says something that pays off even
more when we learned she was the one
that killed the kid on the Black Sea
mission after all those years of doing
your dirty work making the hard
decisions you never had the nerve to
make after all a he who remains in
season 1 was very much trying to shape a
luy variant into something where one of
these eventually would take over from
him he stated that he paved the path
which is something he also brings up
during this finale luy referred to he
who remains as the devil to kill the
devil maybe he was but he clearly saw
how him being in charge was actually a
good thing in the long term this was
represented during the time on the
ferris wheel where he protected Victor
because in the end he understood the
grand scheme of things ly himself
somewhat represents a devil 2 as he has
a thorn crown and was tossed Out of
Heaven he realized that a god needed to
be the one in control and brought this
up during the automat conversation
annihilating is easy
hope it's hard whatever we do we're
playing God we are Gods Lok even says
that they should just keep an eye on the
Kang variant and try and let the rest of
the universe have free will bring him
behind the curtain show him all of this
and then just send him home this is what
he basically does in the end with the
TVA watching over them all to make sure
they don't rise up however they
definitely will do at some point and
Loki can only protect the branches he's
able to hold my variants are already out
there I won't stop doesn't matter never
stopped me before I know CH this makes
me think that he who remains was one of
the ones that managed to escape and
though Loki tried to wipe them out he
wasn't able to do it at the moment we
have a lot of people asking what's going
to happen with Jonathan Majors as he's
about to enter a big controversial trial
I think right I think they'll be like
the TVA right we will keep an eye on
Kang and see how Jonathan Major's trial
goes and if he's found guilty then hey
guess what we managed to keep an eye on
him but if he's found not guilty then oh
god oh no the Multiverse is collapsing
now Loki may become the god of stories
though I have other theories for later
about how he could be a mix however in
episode 3 when we encountered the BAL of
the Brave statue it was a bit weird that
Loki wasn't there potentially he may
have written himself out of History
which is in the aftermath of this ending
alaki became the perfect replacement for
he who remains when we saw the actions
that he took throughout the series in
episode 5 he recruited all the TVA
members and very much brought them
together to start things aresh this in a
way is like its own Ora borrow which the
entire season has been symbolical of is
symbolical a word either way glorious
purpose was the name of the first entry
in season 1 and we close out with this
finale being called that as well I am
Loki of Asgard and I am burdened with
glorious purpose everything in the end
Loops in its own cycle creating this
world tree that holds it all together
the world tree was first introduced in
phase one with both references in Thor
and the first Captain America perhaps ly
even had it put back in time to have
himself created in the same way that the
book was given to Victor that led to he
who remains I think imagery of the tree
has been Lac throughout the show with
the male shet above OB looking exactly
like one branches pruning all these are
words used throughout the show that
helped to pull together this whole tree
idea on top of this the bridge also
resembled a bifrost which brings things
full circle from the first th for
you for all of us for all of us
no Loki no I had Loki having a
transformative moment on a bridge with
it breaking up and then him going off
the edge I even think that the time
Stone being green could be linked to
that but let me know below if you
disagree now if you're enjoying this
video and want to support the channel
then please pick up our Loki inspired
shirt we've got that linked right below
the video and is your glorious purpose
to to go and treat yourself although
there's been Rumblings of Dr Doom lately
I actually think that ly might be at the
hot of Secret Wars in the 2015 version
Doom sat at the center of the tree
controlling the Multiverse or what was
left of it that's very much what we see
Loki doing here with him being at the
heart of all these different timelines
this also plays in the god of stories
arc on which a young Loki traveled to
the end of time here he found an older
version of himself controlling it all
and it was from here that he started to
change his role as a villain Loki had
always been used as a stepping stone and
someone that would Propel others into
greatness here Loki's sort of doing that
as well but he's gone above and beyond
being angered by that happening now he
sees his glorious purpose as carrying
the burden so that his friends can live
their lives free without pruning however
Kang he will still be out there and
inevitably though he tries his best he
will still rise up and start a war Loki
in the TVA can only manage so much and
thus this is something that's no doubt
coming this could be what's happening
with raona who we see down in the void
after being pruned he who remains did
did say that she was the one who helped
win the war and thus I think she's still
a very important player either way at
this point it seems like she's
approached by ath but I actually think
that it might be someone else little
little peek behind the curtain here and
I I'll tell you where I am when I'm at
recording this so this is going to be
going out Saturday but I am writing and
recording it on Friday morning right
after posting off an olly breakdown
loads of thoughts uh went be on the
Easter eggs and I thought i' just put
them out into this video now members of
the channel they got to see this early
and you can get that by clicking The
Joint button and paying just 99 cents a
month very very cheap uh either way
though I think that this might not be a
liath and instead my theory now is that
this is in fact K Kang's colors are also
purple too and we know this is right
beside the pyramid in Sphinx this
variant was potentially shown during
Quantum Mania but either way he's a very
important figure the Sphinx was what
Kang used as a Time ship as well and I
feel like ramit got pruned along with
his trophies this means that he's now
down there to alongside what could be
mred Griffin Griffin was the one who
started up King Enterprises and he
bought Avengers Tower which we saw in
the void either way I think they may
destroy the TVA which was foreshadowed
by what we saw on the ground in the end
she doesn't look afraid and instead she
looks ready for what's going to come now
as for mbius he then returns home but we
see that there's a variant of him with
his kid not sure what's going to happen
here you know will he kill him and do a
wreck and Morty and take over his life
but I don't think that's going to happen
and I think he's going to go back to the
TVA all this really seems is that it's a
Hiatus and that he's going to be needed
for what's about to come it's been
reported that Owen Wilson is in Deadpool
3 so I feel like he's going to return
back the only person whose fate we don't
really know is sis and she might return
to the McDonald's or go somewhere else
the whole point now though is that she
has a choice and I think she still has
he who remains temporal device so could
easily go on the timeline anywhere
however she can also go back to Loki and
I feel like that's what she's going to
end up having to do Loki is now sat at
the end of time and he's probably going
to need to step in when K gets too much
now that could take us to the Avengers
Prime story in which Loi becomes a
titular character he ended up going to
the end of time where he became a God
that lued overall learning of his losses
in the other timelines he then wiped out
the Avengers wherever they beat him
however this left the door open for more
multiversal threats unless he then had
to assemble a team to help fight this
this led to him getting Avengers
throughout time which could be the role
that he has in secret Wars all in all
there's a lot to look forward to and I
really can't wait to see where things go
from here this was such a good way to
end the show and I think they could have
even been like they should have ended it
after Loki season 2 either way are you
one of those people have you changed it
from the should have ended after end
game to now Loki season 2 let me know
below and uh drop a comment where you
want to see things go please hit the
thumbs up button again sorry for asking
all the time and if you want to support
the channel as a member of the spoiler
Society then please click the join
button now if you want some El to watch
you've got a full breakdown of the
episode which is linked on screen right
now we've also got a video for Captain
Marvel so definitely head over if you've
been binging the MCU this weekend out
the way huge thank you for taking shot
the video I've been your host Paul and
I'll see you next time take care peace